so there's some of our viewers who's
very curious about your your mark in
your forehead the white Mark can you
tell me what that means for you
um like I do it um because my mother my
mother said it very early on so I it's
just my practice I do it uh every time
every day and does it bring luck um I'm
not sure um yeah I'm just not sure
sometimes sometimes not good luck to you
BG thank
you
when the Hindus were successful in
meditation you will see that this part
of your forehead seems to become active
literally you can feel it it kind of
lighting up this part of the forehead so
that's why they say let's mark it as a
holy spot if a sh means believe in the
idea of God and sha you have a mark made
of you know three three lines going
across or just a single line going
across with
Ash because Shiva stands for
pronunciation so this like the Sha
tradition